ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนค่ะผู้หญิง
คะคุยเขียนใช่ค่ะลูกติดเขียนได้นะพี่เอ๋
JA เป็นไร
ค่ะวูอะไรเนี่ยขอโทษค่ะขอโทษ
กูเห็นลบอันนี้ก่อน
งูผู้หญิงวันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วัน
พฤหัสบดีค่ะวันนี้วันพระพฤหัสบดีค่ะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 16 ค่ะ 16 นัด
เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
มิถุนายนปีพตอะไรคะเมื่อปีพ.ศ
2565 ค่ะปีคศอะไรคะปีคศ 2  022 ค่ะตอน
นี้เวลากี่โมงคะตอนนี้เวลา
04:50 น
4:50 นนะคะค่ะ
นักเรียนก็รู้วันเวลาหน้าขา
ผมก็เป็นนะคะ
ได้ค่ะลบ
ๆ
ผู้หญิงครับครูเอกมีคำถามไม่มีเข้าเท้า
แบบมีคำถามคำถามอะไรคะคำถามนิดหน่อยคนไทย
ถามได้นะคะนักเรียนนักศึกษาถามไม่ได้
กรีเงียบถามถามว่าครูหญิงเดี๋ยวไปวัดก่อน
ผู้หญิง
คุณ
ครูหญิงน่ะ
แม่นไหม
ไม่เป็นต้องเป็นผลอีกอ่ะ
คิวโอ้ยเดี๋ยวนี้ผู้หญิงคิ้วยาว
ปิ๊งเขียนค่ะ
แล้วก็ตา
ร้านเล็กๆจมูกต้อง
เอาจิ้มฟันใหญ่ๆนะคะ
ต่อ
สองร้อยแล้วครับอะไรคะครูเอกเวทย์ถามอะไร
ครูหญิงฮะอ้าอาบปีนี้ค่ะปี
2022 เนี่ยครูหญิงอายุเท่าไหร่นะคะครู
หญิงอายุ 17 ค่ะ
ตกใจ
นักเรียนหรอครูหญิงตัวเองผู้หญิง
ชาแนลนี้ห้ามโกหกขอพี่ใช่ไหมคิดผิดๆๆตี๋
ไม่ได้
ห้ามกล่องยังพูดไม่จบ
ครูหญิงอายุ 17  +  20
ตกใจเหมือนกัน
เป็นน้ำเขียนเลยค่ะอายุ 17 แล้วก็บวก
27 ปีอันนี้แบบโกหกไม่ได้กูจะบอกยังพูด
ไม่เสร็จ 17 แล้วก็บวก 20 อ่ะเอาเท่าไหร่
นักเรียนคิดเองโอเคเนาะ
หนาว 17 ค่ะครูเอ๋อุดได้นะคะจ้าๆแรงคู๋
17th ถามอายุครูหญิงทำไมอามาถามอายุก่อน
แล้วผู้หญิงอยากรู้อายุคู่เองไหมคะกูเห็น
พูดได้ไหมคะบอกได้ไหมพูดได้อ๋อครูเอ๋คะปี
นี้ 2,000  22 ครูเอ๋อายุ 60 เท่าไหร่คะ
อะไรนะ
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
ทำไมหน้ากูเองนะกูบอกว่าผู้หญิงพูดอันนี้
กูเห็นหน้าตาเลยโอ้กูเองต้องอันนี้ไหมคะ
นักเรียนต้อง
[เพลง]
โกรธมั้ยเนี่ยครูฮิตผู้หญิงนี่บ่กล้วย
อายุ 60 เท่าไหร่อีกเร็วๆอบกะ 10 โทรหาย
เอาไม่ใช่หรอไม่ใช่
ผู้หญิงพูดไม่ดีอีกแล้วเนื้อหาชาแนลนี้
ไม่ได้ไม่ได้คู่หญิงต้องถามอายุไม่ต้อง
บอกอายุขอครูเอ๋คะบีนี้ครูเอ๋อายุเท่า
ไหร่ครูเอ๋อายุ 27 ปีค่ะครูเอกคะตาแนวนี้
ถ้าห้ามโกหก
ไม่ยังพูดไม่เสร็จขอ
สิบเจ็ดคูณ
ด้วยนะผมลบตรงนี้ก่อนอ่ะ 27 ปีแต่ว่าครูน
on  27  *  2  2  *  7 เป็น 14 ใส่ 4 ท์
1  2 คูณ 2 เป็น 6 อ๊อด 74 ปีผู้หญิง
เรียนหนังสือหรือยังเป็น
The  topic แล้วช่วยไปจากอายุสิได้ไป
2 คูณ 74 ใส่ 4 ท์ 1
ข้าง 2  *  2 นะ 4 ถุงร้อง
ก็เป็น
27 นักเรียนไม่เป็นไรค่ะ 54  8 หน้าหน้า
ไม่ใช่ 54 สูงช่วย
กูเห็นลบอายุก่อนนะคะนักเรียนเดี๋ยวนัก
เรียนจะอยู่นานๆแล้วร้องไห้อายุหรือค่ะ
ครูเอ๋ถามครูหญิงน่ะเรื่องอายุนะคะอายุนะ
ค่ะ with
อะไร
รึเปลี่ยนสีเธอเปลี่ยนเปลี่ยนแอบโอเคครู
เอ๋ถามผู้หญิงเรื่องอายุเพราะว่านักเรียน
จะได้รู้ตอนนี้ครูหญิงเป็นผู้ใหญ่เอาอ๋อ
อ๋อใช่ผู้หญิงอายุ 37 แล้วเป็นผู้ใหญ่ไป
ใช่เด็กค่ะให้ใช่วัยรุ่นไม่ใช่เอาแล้ว
เด็กหรือวัยรุ่นต้องอายุเท่าไหร่คะท่าน
เด็กก็อายุเด็กก็เราก็บอกว่าตั้งแต่อายุ 3
1 ปีก็ได้เนาะอันนี้เด็กทารกเด็ก 1 ปีก็
แบบคลานแล้วถึง 12 ปีเนี่ยเด็กค่ะแล้ววัย
รุ่นล่ะคะครูเอ๋
13-19 ปี
หอมไปรุ่นนะเอาถ้าอายุ 20 ปีขึ้นไปเป็น
ผู้ใหญ่หนุ่มสาวเป็นหนุ่มเป็นสาวแต่ไพ่ 25
ปีขึ้นไปน่ะ
ผู้ใหญ่โอ๋
เป็นผู้ใหญ่แล้วนะคะพี่กับครูเอกก็เป็น
ผู้ใหญ่แล้วไม่ใช่เด็กครูเอกผู้ใหญ่มากๆๆ
ๆผู้ใหญ่ค่ะทุกคนผู้ใหญ่
ผู้หญิงครูหญิงเนี่ยเป็นผู้ใหญ่แล้วเนาะ
อ้าแต่เป็นผู้ใหญ่มานานโต้ชักคิดถึงอายุ 1
ถึง 12 ปีผู้หญิงกอล์ฟผ่านไปก็ต้องประมาณ
25 ปีได้ค่ะ
25 ปีที่แล้ว 25 ปีที่แล้วจำได้เนาะจริง
ได้ลายครูเอ๋นะคะอ่ะมีผู้ใหญ่มากี่ปีแล้ว
42 ปีที่แล้วโห
ผู้ S เป็นผู้ใหญ่นานกว่าครูหญิงเป็นคน
นี่ล่ะจะพูดอะไร
คือผู้ใหญ่ว่าเป็นเด็กเป็นเด็กเป็นเด็ก
เนี่ยเป็นเด็ก 4  12 ปีที่แล้วครูยิง 25
ปีที่แล้วเป็นเด็กนะคะวันนี้จะให้ผู้หญิง
คิดถึงเมื่อก่อน
ตอนครูหญิงเด็กๆหรอคะคู๋ๆต่อที่คุณหญิง
เป็นเด็กนะคะเป็นเด็กอ่ะอย่าถามกูหญิงว่า
กู้หญิงเป็นเด็กดีหรือไม่ดี
เอาเมื่อก่อน
มากนะมากๆผู้หญิงเป็นเด็กดีหรืออุ้ยดีคะ
อุ้ยทติงเป็นเด็กดีค่ะเด็กดีเด็กดีอายุ
1-12 เนี่ยเป็นเด็กผู้หญิงนะเป็นเด็กดี
ชอบเรียน
ฟังคุณพ่อคุณแม่ไม่พูดไม่พูด
เป็นเด็กดีนะคะแล้วครูเอ๋ล่ะคะ
42 ปีที่แลก
22 ปีครูเอ๋เนี่ยที่โรงเรียน
โรงเรียนนะคะ
โรงเรียนเนี่ยฮึ
พี่โรงเรียนที่สีแดงเนาะ
สีแดงสีน้ำเงินธงนี้เป็นธงนะคะธงชาติที่
โรงเรียนที่โรงเรียนมีคุณครู
คุณครูผู้ชายคุณครูผู้หญิง
เพราะครูเอ๋
เป็นเด็กนักเรียน
คุณครูบอกว่า F เป็นเด็กดีมามากหนูยังตอน
เด็กๆครูเอ๋ก็เป็นเด็กดีเด็กดีมากที่โรง
เรียนอ้าวแล้วที่บ้านเหรอคะครูเอ๋เป็น
เด็กดีไหมอันนี้ที่บ้าน
ที่โรงเรียนครูเอกก็แบบ
เป็นเด็กดีอาเป็นเด็กดี
โรงเรียนน่ะครูบอกโอ็ต dek  d แอดดีมาก
ที่บ้าน
คนพ่อ
พ่อคูณแม่
แม่จะบอกเอ๋เองเด็กไม่ดิแล้วคุณพ่อล่ะคุณ
พ่อบอกครูเอ๋เป็นเด็กดีไหมคะคุณพ่อก็บอก
ทำไมไม่ดี
ครูเองไม่เป็นเด็กไม่ดีครูเห็นทำอะไรอ่ะ
คุณพ่อคุณแม่เลยบอกครูเอ๋เป็นเด็กไม่ดี
เวลาคู๋เด็กๆอ่ะครูเอ๋ไม่ชอบพูดกับคน
เอ้าแล้วครูเอ๋พูดกับใครกูพูดกับ
ควาย
แง
พูดจับ
หมา
เหมือนไม่เนี่ยพูดกับหมาหนาๆอ่าอันแล้ว
ครูเอกก็พูดกับมด
ครูเอ๋พูดกับควายพูดกับหมาพูดกับมดยังไง
อ่ะกูเอกก็พูดกับควายก็สวัสดีควายสบายดี
ไหม
คิ้วโอเคกินห้ามแห่อันนี้นี่ใช่ไหมค่ะดี
กูเองพูดกับหมาหมาทำไมนอน
แน่
กูเอกก็พูดกับหมาก็โอเค
รียครูเอ๋นะมันรัก
กูเองพูดกับมดมดทำอะไรหมดก็ไม่สนใจแล้วก็
เดินๆ
มดอะไรมันก็เดินๆๆโอเคไหมอ่ะเอ่อ
แล้วมดก็เดินมาแล้วหมดมีหนวดหนวดแล้วมดก็
เอาหนวดมาอ่ะคุยกันหนวดมาชนไงฉันไม่สนนะ
พี่เอ๋
Mode  without หนวดมาชนกันเหรอคะครูเอ๋
มันเดินมันไม่พูดอ่ะ
วัวควายมาแนหมายอาญาหมดไม่พูดหมดก็เอา
หนวดเนี่ยชนกันค่ะชนกันแล้วก็แล้วก็ไปบท
แบบนี้เลยผู้หญิงหมดสีดำๆอันนี้เรียกมด
อะไรอ่ะมดดำคงตัวใหญ่นะคะเนี่ยไก่คู่เอก
ก็โกรธอ่ะผู้หญิง
เรทมบไอ้โอเคไหมคะก็หมดไม่พูดกับเอ๋ไอ้ก็
โกรธไง
อายุเท่าไหร่ครับโกรธมด
8 ปี 8 ปีอาแล้วครูเอ๋โกรธมดเกรดทำยังไง
ฝากกดมดพ่อมดนะมดเดินแล้วก็ชนกันแล้วก็ไป
6 ชนกันแล้วก็ไปหมดพูดอะไรอุ๊ยพูดอะไร
ทำไมต้องเอาหนวดชนกันกูอีกก็คิดคริบ
ถ้าไม่มีหนวดแหละ
ขอหมดจะพูดจะพูดอ่ะหรอ
มันคือถ้าไม่มีหนวดหมดจะเป็นทีมเอ๋ใช่ไหม
หือแล้วหมดไม่มีหนวดได้ยังไงก็มดมันมีนวด
กูเอกก็จับมดมาสิแล้วก็เอ๊ะจุดบนมาทำอะไร
เด็กหน่วน
เด็กด่วนโง่เขจะจับมดมาเด็ดหนวดกี่ตัว
ครั้งที่หนึ่งอ้ะตัวนึงก่อนอ๊อด
เอกนี่เลยหนวดก็เนี้ยกูเอกเน็ตหนวดออกไป
เด็ดหนวดออกไปค่ะกูหมดนวดและสั้นๆ
ละมุดเดินเดินคนเดือนได้ไหมเดินให้ด้วยนะ
เอกก็ปล่อยมดเดินกดก็เดินเดินแล้วมันก็
เดินมาเจอเพื่อน
คุยได้ไหมคุยไม่ได้เพื่อนโกรธเพื่อน
สู้เลย
หู
คู่เอกก็เห็นมวยหมดขอภดชกกัน
สนุกมากผู้หญิงกาแฟทำยังไงอ่ะกูเอกก็ได้
จับมดตัวที่ 2 เด็ดหนวดมด
แล้วก็เอาหมดมาสู้กันเอามดตัวที่หนึ่งกู a
สู้เองเลยเหรอคะ
ไม่ๆกูเอ๋ทำทำแบบนี้ทับที่ดินแบบนี้แล้ว
ก็ให้หมดเนี่ย 2 ตัวนะอยู่ข้างใน
แล้วพอมันไม่มีหนวดคุยกันหมดมันก็เลยสู้
กันได้กูอ่ะไม่รู้ว่าตัวไหนเป็น
แชมป์เปี้ยนค่ะแม่กูอีกอย่า
ก็เชียร์ใช่มั้ยเดี๋ยวมากๆค่ะผู้หญิงรู้
มั้ยเดี๋ยวนะตัวเองทั้งหมดก่อนซื้ออันนี้
หมดใช่ไหมคะหมดตู้กันนี่กระดูหมดสู้
กันใช่ไหมหนึ่งเอ๊ยต่อย Love ใหญ่ๆสนุก
มากนักเรียนสนะอ่าค่ะมวยไทยหน้าตั้งแล้ว
หรอคะโรงเรียนไม่คุยกับมดนะคะมีบ้านใช่
ไหมบ้านอ่าบ้าน
ที่บ้านนักเรียนแล้วก็ก็อันนี้หน้าบ้านจะ
และหลังบ้านหน้าบ้านหลังบ้านที่เนี้ยกู
อยู่ตรงเนี้ยไกลจากหลังบ้านประมาณ 300
เมตร
ดูมวยหมดอ้ะนะมวยหมดมีต้นไม้มีต้นไม้แถว
นี้แล้วกูเอกก็เสียงดังถ้าไม่กลับบ้าน
เล่นกับพจน์นานๆ
แล้วเกิดอะไรขึ้นไม่กินข้าวไงอ๋ออ๋อกูเอก
ก็คืนดูมดหัดหนวดมดดูมดชกมวยไม่กลับบ้าน
ไม่ค่ะ
เพลงลูก
สนุกมากค่ะพระอาทิตย์น่ะ
พระอาทิตย์เป็นยังไงคะหน้าพระพระอาทิตย์
ที่นี่ใช่ไหมคะค่ะพระอาทิตย์เริ่มตกๆโง้
ผู้เอกก็เองเองไม่ร้อนแล้วก็ตอนเนี้ยคิด
ว่าตั้งแต่
11:00 น
ตั้งแต่ 11:00 นจนถึงพระอาทิตย์ตกเลยเหรอ
คะครูเอ๋อ่านห้ามยังไม่ตกดีประมาณ 17:00
นวุ่นวายกันมาก
ก็
สนุกคนเดียวค่ะให้กินข้าวเอาแล้วคุณพ่อ
คุณแม่โอเคเหรอคะครูเอ๋ไม่กลับบ้านกิน
ข้าว
พ่อแม่เองเอเชียที่ไหนเอ๋ที่ไหน aaaaa
ที่ไหนอ่ะแล้วก็เอกก็สนุกชื่อว่าใจ
เสียงดัง
เสียงดังแล้วเป็นยังไงต่อคะ
แม่ได้ยินอันนี้แม่
ได้ยินได้ยินเสียงครูเอ๋เตรียมอวยหมดแล้ว
อ่ะ
ชื่อเสียงทางวาดเพราะว่าลืมเย้
เอ้าสนุกฉันสนุกไปเย้เย้
อะไรเนี่ยทำไมแพ้เอาใหม่เอกก็หยิบอีก 1
ตัวกำลังจะเด็ด
การรู้สึกมันมีสะกิดน้องมีใครมาสะกิดแล้ว
กูเองได้ไปเก็บข้างหลังต้องทำยังไงเป็น
อะไร
ใครคะแม่
โหแม่มาสะกิดครูเอ๋
แม่ไม่ได้มาธรรมดาแม่มายังแม่มา
แล้วก็มีไม้เรียวงูงูเอกอยู่นี่ค่ะคุยก็
นั่งนั่งเชียร์มดนั่งหยิบมดมากำลังจะเด็ด
ดวดมดแม่เนี่ยมือถือไม้เรียวอุ้ยคู๋เล็กๆ
กูเอกไม่ชอบเล็กๆอ่ะอ๋อไม้เรียวเอกกลัว
ไหมคุณแม่ถือไม้เรียวมาคุณแม่บอกเด็กไม่
ดี
เสียงข้างนะหรอครูเอ๋เป็นเด็กไม่ดีพูด
เสียงดัง
เด็กไม่ดีแต่แม่พูดเสียงดังนะแม่ก็ไม่ดี
สิจ๊ะ
เฮ้ยเด็กไม่ดีไม่ใช่เด็กพูดเสียงดังเด็กๆ
หนวดมดแม่อ๋อ
แม่นทำไมเด็ดหนวดมดเด็กไม่ดีมดทำอะไรเด็ด
หนวดมท 1 วันหัวกูเอกจะเจ็บเหมือนมดมด
เจ็บปวดใช่ไหมหมด a เด็ดมดเจ็บ
แม่บอกมดอาเหมณข้าขี้ยังแม่จะพูดอะไร West
เถียงอะไรคะหมดไม่เจ็บ
ฮือทำไมพูดบ่อยไม่เจ็บแม่ 3 เลย
ทำไมมดไม่เจ็บหมดไม่ร้อง
ถ้า n เด็ดหมดหนวดมดนะมดเจ็บโมโตะโอ้ยใช่
มั้ยอ๋ออย่าเอาหมาเอาตีหมา
S เองตัวเองตัวเองๆอะนี่มันเจ็บจริงๆๆ
เองตัวเองซุงตัดอะไรต้องเชียร์ดำเองเอง
ใช่ไหมเราตีหมาหมาๆเจ็บอ่ะตีน้องกูเอทตี้
โอ้ย
เจมส์โอย
โมะแต่โดนหนวดไอ้โดนเด็ดหนวดหมดไม่พูด
เจ็บไม่มี
เนื้อแม่ก็น่ากูเอกก็ได้อีกนะคะ
ทำไมเด็กไม่ดี
ก็แทบเจ็บมันร้องไงก็บอกว่ามดพูดไม่ได้
เอาอ๋อ
ได้ก็บอก
หมดต้องพูดได้สิแม่บอกหมดพูดไม่ได้เห็น
มั้ยเด็ดหนวดมดก็เลยคุยกับเพื่อนไม่ได้
เพื่อนเพื่อนๆมันก็กัดกัดกัดมือไม่ใช่กัด
อันนี้มวยมด
เจ้าแม่ว่ายังไงคุณแม่ก็เลยจะกลับบ้านมี
หมายครูเอกเดินๆกลับบ้านคุณแม่มีไม้นะ
กลับบ้านเสร็จ
เมียนนี้คุณดิที่บ้านคุณแม่เนี่ยก็มีค่ะ
มีตัวเล็กชั่นค่ะ Collection อะไรคะครู
เอ๋เขามีไม้
aight
เล็กๆ
ดี
ใจ
C
ใหญ่ๆโอ๋
ดี
อีกหรอคะไม่หมดค่ะแม่มีเยอะแม่มีเยอะ
รี่เป็นยังไงคะไม้ดีเป็นใบไม้
ก้านไม้เขาอ๋อ
หน้าแม่มีนะคะ ay  ay  ay น่ะคืออันนี้
เล็กๆอ่ะส่วน BB จะใหญ่กว่านี้นิดนึง
บีทำไมคุยไม่เอาวันนี้เนาะ
b
c  o  c  size นี้เลยนะแบบมีหูสีใหญ่มาก
อันนี้ค่ะ 4 โหตีเราก็ดีดี
เป็น
ใบมากั้นกิ่งไม้หมูเล็กๆสั้นๆๆ
เล็กสุดก็น่าจะเป็นดีนี่ล่ะค่ะดีน่ะอันดี
คือตอนนี้อันเนี้ยต้นมะยมหมออันไหนคะเอา
อันนี้หรอคะอันนี้ค่ะอันนั้นอ๋อการมะยม
เล็กๆๆแบบนี้เลยนี่แหละอีกแล้ว
ผู้หญิงเคยโดนตีมั้ย
กริ่งเคยโดนตีมากการไว้องค์ไหมไม่ใช่
คุณมีเอจะมาอ้าผู้หญิงผู้หญิงเดี๋ยวก่อน
ใครปีค่ะคุณแม่พ่อมาท่านผู้หญิงเด็กไว้ดี
ใช่ไหมๆสายๆเด็กไหมดีเด็กตีน้องขอกู้หญิง
ปีน้องน้องเจ็บร้องให้คุณพ่อตรติคุณพ่อ
ไม่มีให้เลือกเหรอคะไม่มีค่ะไม่มีคุณพ่อ
หยิบไม้เราก็ตีอุ้ยคุณแม่กูเองให้เลือกโห
abcd เนี่ยอ่ะคะนายคุณแม่ถามว่าไปเลือก
มาชอบอะไรอ่อแล้วครูเอ๋เลือกอะไรคู๋ IQ
ดี EQ เอ๋เอา
c-47 ซีมันใช้นะครูเอ๋ทำไมกูเองไม่เอาดี
เล็กๆๆแบบนี้เลยนักเรียน
เอาดีนะคะ
ดีอ่ะไม่ดี
ทำไมอะดีคุณแม่ตีแล้วบ่เจ็บที่สุดหรอ
โอ้นี่นักเรียนเล็กๆเนี่ยเจ็บที่สุดขอไป
โอเคก้อนเก๋ไอคิวดีไม่ใช่ค่ะครูเอ๋โดนตี
บ่อยๆรู้แล้วไม่ใช่ครูเอ๋เห็น
เห็น Play มีพี่สาวพี่ชายครูเอ๋น้องชาย
พี่ชายกับน้องชายน่ะ 2 คนเด็กไม่ดีเหมือน
ครูเอ่ะขอก็เห็นคุณแม่เนี่ยเอาเล็กๆปี
พี่ชายกับน้องชายชอบครั้งที่ 1 ดีกูเห็น
ดูเมื่อก่อนนะกูเห็นอ่าพี่ชายกับน้องชาย
บ่โอเคเอาดีแล้วก็ตีเลิศสองคนก็เอ้ยเจ็บ
ด้วยกัน
แล้วสักครั้งที่ 2  2 คนขอเปลี่ยนเป็น A
2 คนก็ Oil เจ็บๆสองคนก็เปลี่ยนเป็นบี
เจ็บแต่สองคนไม่ยอมไม่ยอมเอา
c41 ใหญ่ไงๆก็ไม่เอาสิก็จะเอาเองกับดีบี
ก็ไม่เอาพี่ชายกับน้องชายจะเลือก a กับ D
B น่ะครั้งเดียว 2 คนคิดว่าไม้ใหญ่เจ็บ
มากกว่าเล็ก
ใช่แต่ครูเอ๋เรื่อง
ใหญ่ใช่ไหมพี่เอกคิดเจ็บน้อยกว่าหรอไม่
รู้ไงก่อนเอกก็เลือกคิดใหญ่ดูว่าเจ็บน้อย
ไปใหญ่เสร็จแล้วเนี่ยคุณแม่ตีนอ่ะแม่
เขียนใหญ่ใช่มั้ยแม่ก็ติดอิก้นนะคะนัก
เรียนค่ะอ่าปีที่นี่
อา
ตีตรงนี้แม่ก็เด็กไม่ดี
นักเรียนเจ็บมั้ยแม่ตี
ขอโทษนะคุณแม่จริงๆไม่เจ็บ
แต่ต้อง Action เจ็บ
แต่ไม่เด็กไม่ดีคุณแม่ก็จะได้ตีไม่เยอะ
ขึ้นไหมเบาๆๆคุณแม่ก็ไม่รู้ว่าไม้ใหญ่นะ
มันไม่เจ็บคุณแม่ก็คิดเจ็บคุณแม่ก็บอก
แม่ก็คิดไม้เล็กๆไม่เจ็บคุณแม่ก็ตีแรงๆ
หน้าที่คุณแม่ต้องตีเพราะว่าครูเอ๋น่าไป
ไปทำมดเจ็บน้ำที่ใกล้เด็ดหนวดมดเวลาที่
เราไปเด็ดหนวดมดไปตีหมา We  Are ไปไปตีคน
อื่นคนอื่นร้องไห้เจ็บคุณแม่ก็จะ
ตีไม่ตีเสือพูดด้วยนะไม่เด็กไม่ดี
อย่าทำเขานะเขาเจ็บเดี๋ยว 1 วันเอ๋เจ็บ
เหมือนมด
ไม่เก่งเอ๋ไม่ใช่หมดแค่นักเรียนใครจะเจ็บ
หัวเหมือนหมดเนาะ
[เพลง]
แตกผู้หญิงเชื่อไม้มีอะไรคะมีวันหนึ่ง
เกิดอะไรขึ้นครับผู้หญิงครูเอ๋เจ็บเหมือน
มด
เจ็บที่หัวเนี่ยนะกูเป็นมุกเหรอคะๆ
ประมาณประมาณอันนี้ผู้หญิงประมาณ
1-2 ปีมั้ง
คู๋เด็ดหมดประมาณ
พวก 8 ไม่ใช่ไหมคะค่ะ 9 ขวบดีเลี้ยวเอง
เดียวปีเดียว
ตอนการอายุ 9 ขวบ
คนที่หัวเป็นอะไร
ที่อันนี้ครูเอ๋ค่ะและเด็กๆ
คู๋นอน
นอนแล้วก็ตื่นขึ้นมาโอ้ยเจ็บปวดหัว
ทำเฟ้ยปวดหัวหรือเปล่าไปชายมันเจ็บตรงนี้
เจ็บที่นี่เจ็บเอาไม่เจ็บทั้งหมดอุ้ยทำไม
เหมือนหมดเลย
เจ็บ
เจ็บที่หัวอีกแล้วของแม่เออดูดูๆเจ็บที่
หัวก็ดู
คุณแม่ก็ดูหรอคะเห้ยที่บ้านคุณแม่คุณป้า
พ่อดูหมดกูเองมีแบบนี้ตัวอะไรอ่ะครูเอ๋
โหลดมนต์ไม่ใช่มันเหมือนที่หน้าแล้วใหญ่ๆ
ไม่ใช่สิวนะ
ทั้งสีแดงๆนักเรียนเอาเอาเพลงมันจะมีเส้น
ใช่ไหมคู๋มันจะบวมขึ้นมานักเรียนมันเป็น
อย่างนี้ค่ะ
อันนี้อันนี้เป็นหัวเป็นหัวเรานะค่ะหัว
แล้วมันก็บวมขึ้นมาแบบนี้
122 ค่ะผู้หญิงค่ะมันแดงๆขึ้นมาแล้วก็มี
สีเหลืองเหลืองๆ
เขาเรียกอะไรครูเอ๋เอ๋ไม่ใช่สิวใช่ไหมที่
หน้าเล็กๆสิวแต่อันนี้ตรงเนี้ยใหญ่ๆค่ะ
หนีกูฝีเจ็บมาก
ขวาแล้วก็สายอยู่กันหมดใช่โอ๊ย
เจ็บว่าออยเจ็บแม่เขาทำยังไงแล้วก็รอจน
ใหญ่ๆใหญ่ๆแล้วมันก็บึงแตก
ปุ๊บโอเคไหมหายเจ็บต้องใส่ใส่ยา
นักเรียนครู a นะเจ็บเหมือนมดเลยแค่
ฉันเจ็บเหมือนมดคนไทยบอกว่า
กรรมใช่มั้ย
กรรมคู๋ธรรมดเจ็บชายแล้วก็มีเจ็บ
เหมือนมด
อันนี้กรรมค่ะ
คุณแม่บอกใช่ไหม
พ2อันเสร็จแล้วคุยก็สบายใจไม่เสร็จแล้ว
ผู้หญิงมีอะไรอีกคะครูเอ๋ซึ่งตรงนี้อีก 2
อันนี้
อ่า
ใส่ผู้หญิงอะไรก็เลยแล้วก็มีที่ป่าอีก 1
อันคู๋ไม่ได้เด็ดหนวดมท 1 ตัวไงเห็นเด็ด
มากวะชายเห็นไหมเป็นกรรมนะคะพูดเอ๋เป็น
เด็กไม่ดิ
ครูเอ๋คิดสนุกใช่ไหมนักเรียน 8 เด็กๆไม่
เข้าใจบาปจำไม่เข้าใจคุณแม่บอกไม่ดีบาป
กรรม 1 วันจะเจ็บเหมือนมดโอ๊ะ 1 ปีคู๋เลย
เจ็บเหมือนมดเพราะว่ามีบาปกรรมเข้าใจหรือ
ยังเข้าใจแล้วค่ะใจแล้วนักเรียนเองทำไม
คู๋มีฝี
เพราะว่ากูเอกกินอันนี้ค่ะกินอะไรคะ
ก๋วยเตี๋ยวเนื้อวัว Mall โป้
นักเรียนก็กินก๋วยเตี๋ยวเนื้อวัวอ้ะนัก
เรียนกินโอเคแต่กูเอกกินแล้วจะมีฝีหัวมัน
ไม่โอเคใช่ไหมตอนนั้นไม่โอเคกับร่างกาย
เอ๋นะคะค่ะน้องก็เป็นก๋วยเตี๋ยวเนื้อวัว
จะมีสีเออนะคะบ่าครูเอ๋ถ่ายบาปกรรมถ่ายกู
mm ตอนนี้ไม่เด็ดแล้วนะคะขอโทษขอตอนนี้
ไม่แต่ตอนนี้ฉีดเลยไม่สิเอาไม่จิต
มดเต็มบ้านเลยเนี่ย
เห็นหมดไม่เป็นไรเดินเลยโอเค
ไม่ชื่อ
โอเคค่ะหมดเวลาใช่ไหมคะตายค่ะก็ก็ครูเอ
เป็นเด็กไม่ดีนะคะนะขอเสียงผู้หญิงหญิงก็
เด็กดี
จริงๆไม่ดีหรอก็มีเด็กไม่ดีมีเคยไม่ดีนะ
คะวันนี้หน้าค่อยฟังคุยใครไม่ดีอะไรทำ
อะไรไม่ดีนะคะค่ะนั้นแต่ว่าวันนี้เราไป
ก่อนเนาะแล้วเดี๋ยวเจอกันใหม่วิดีโอหน้า
นะคะสวัสดีค่ะ
บ๊ายบายๆ